How to submit assignments. There are two
ways to submit assignments, first, through T-Square, and
second, through the Udacity site. We'll cover
both of these in the orientation, as your
courses will use both methods. Depending on
the format of the assignment. Lets start with
T-Square. T-Square is Georgia's Tech's learning management system.
You will use T-Square, to submit certain assignments.
For example, PDFs and other documents. Your instructor
will provide links to submit assignments on T-Square,
in addition to detailed instructions. Lets walk through
an example, to show you how this will
be done. Let's say that I'm ready to
submit my project for Agile software development, as
part of my software development processes course. I
can access the project instructions from the instructor notes,
through this link here. When I'm ready to submit
my project, I click on the link provided. That'll
take me to the assignment section of the course
on T-Square. Where I can submit the exact assignment.
Because I'm logged into Udacity with Georgia Tech, I'll
be able to access this link to T-Square, without
logging in again. If you have any technical difficulties,
please contact your course manager, through the chat window, or
by emailing gt-support@udacity.com.